so let's talk a little bit about
rational
rational numbers
and the simple way to think about it is
any number that can be represented as
the ratio as the ratio of two integers
is a rational number so for example any
integer is a rational number
one can be represented as one over one
or as negative 2 over negative 2 or as
10 000
over 10 000. in all of these cases these
are all different representations of the
number one ratio of two integers and i
actually obviously can have an infinite
number of representations of one in this
way the same number over the same number
the number
negative seven
could be represented as negative seven
over one or
seven over negative one or negative 14
over positive 2 and i can go on and on
and on and on so negative 7 is
definitely a rational number it can be
represented as the ratio of two integers
but what about things that are not
integers for example
let us imagine well i don't know let's
imagine 3
3.75
how can we represent that as the ratio
of two integers well 3.75
you could you could rewrite that as 375
over
100 which is the same thing as 750
over 200 or you could say hey 3.75 is
the same thing as three and
three-fourths
as three and three-fourths so let me
write here three and three-fourths which
is the same thing as that's 15 over 4. 4
times 3 is 12 plus 3 is 15. so you could
write this
this is the same thing as 15 over 4 or
we could write this as negative
30 over
negative 8. i just multiplied the
numerator and denominator here by
negative 2. but just to be clear this is
clearly rational i'm giving you multiple
examples of how this can be represented
as the ratio as the ratio of two
integers now what about repeating
decimals well let's take maybe the most
famous of the repeating decimals let's
say you have
0.333 just keeps going on and on forever
which we can
denote
by putting that little bar on top of the
three this is 0.3 repeating and we've
seen and
later we'll show that how you can
convert any repeating decimal into a
rational
in as the ratio of two integers
this is clearly 1 over 3 or maybe you've
seen things like 0.6 repeating which is
two over three and there's many many
many other examples of this and we'll
see any repeating decimal not just one
digit repeating as many even if it has a
million digits repeating as long as the
pattern starts to repeat itself over and
over and over again you can always
represent that as the ratio as the ratio
of two integers so i know what you're
probably thinking hey sal you you've
just included a lot you've included all
of the integers you've included all of
non-repeating decimals
or you've all you you've included all of
finite non-repeating decimals and you've
also included repeating decimals what is
left are there any numbers that are not
rational and you're probably guessing
that there are otherwise people wouldn't
have taken the trouble of trying to
label these as rational
and it turns out as you can imagine that
actually some of the most famous numbers
in all of mathematics are not rational
and we call these numbers irrational
irrational
irrational numbers
irrational numbers and i've listed just
a few of the most noteworthy examples pi
the ratio of the circumference of the
the ratio of the circumference to the
diameter of a circle
is an irrational number it it it never
terminates it goes on and on forever and
it never repeats e same thing never
terminates never repeats it comes out of
continuously compounding interest it
comes out of complex analysis e shows up
all over the place square root of two
irrational number phi the golden ratio
irrational number so these things that
really just pop out of nature
many of these numbers are irrational now
you might say okay you know are these
irrational these are just kind of these
special these special kind of numbers
but maybe most numbers are rational and
you know sal's just picked out some
special cases here but the important
thing to realize is they do seem exotic
and they are exotic in certain ways but
they aren't uncommon it actually turns
out that there is at there is always an
irrational number between any two
rational numbers and that well we could
go on and on there's actually an
infinite number but but there's at least
one
so that gives you an idea that it's you
can't really say that there are fewer
irrational numbers than rational numbers
and a future video will prove that you
give me you give me two rational numbers
rational one rational two
rational two there's going to be at
least one irrational number between
those which is a kind of a neat result
because irrational numbers seem to be
kind of exotic another way to think i
took square root of 2 but you take the
square root of any non-perfect square
you're going to end up with an
irrational number you take the sum of an
irrational and a rational number and
we'll see this later on we'll prove it
to ourselves the sum of an irrational
and a rational is going to be irrational
the product of an irrational and
irrational is going to be irrational so
there's a lot a lot a lot of irrational
numbers out there